some of the physical sides of archery is
really trying to align the body getting
your shoulders and wrists at full draw
to all be in a straight line trying to
get the flexibility to get this elbow
line behind the line of the arrow so the
bow which is 50 pounds is trying not to
pull me and make my body collapse but is
making me stronger at full draw so when
I'm aligning my shoulders when you see
that rotation there's a little bit of a
pause there the whole concept behind
that is getting my right shoulder in my
front wrist all in a straight line when
you shoot and you pull the bow back you
have the string and it's sitting like
this so the string just rolls off the
tip of your fingers and we get calluses
on our fingers these are stabilizers
what they do is dampen vibration so a
lot of times when you shoot the bow
there's a lot of vibration that happens
what you want to do is redirect that
away from your hand because up your hand
is showing the site where to be the
stabilizers absorbing that shock is
really crucial for the Olympics each
arrow is specific to each Archer so we
get them at a really long length and
then cut them down so they're specific
to each of us as far as physics go it's
just gonna be like how the weight is on
my bow how much I'm pulling back it's
just like what works for me and I found
a pretty good setup that I stick with
the way I set my shoulders the way I
draw the bow if I would look at myself
and pick a word of be fierce or
determined